ever since the introduction of jump pads
and shooters an FPS that offered greater
freedom of flight was inevitable
lawbreakers feels like one such result
there's a moderate learning curve to
maneuvering and surviving in air and
within the myriad anti-gravity spheres
of the games arenas when you do manage
to adapt to sniping on the fly or
boosting down a corridor with strategic
purpose the resulting outcomes can feel
sublime even if you rarely receive the
post-match MVP award even with the
possibility of vertical movement FPS
maps are wasted if there aren't adequate
weapons and abilities to play with
lawbreakers addresses this challenge
through intelligible diversity in the
armaments and specialties spread across
its nine classes there's a reasonable
assortment of advanced finesse fighters
beginner-friendly gateway classes and
well-rounded combatants who are useful
in any map mode combination even after
about a hundred matches it was pleasing
to see that no one class stood out as
dominant which is a credit to developer
boss keys thoughtfulness in honing these
characters and learning how to optimize
a role based on your team makeup map and
mode is part of the fun which is
perpetuated by the welcomed ability to
change your class's mid-match while
lawbreakers isn't the type of shooter
that awards skill boosting gear as you
level up discovering additional gameplay
depth after getting the hang of flying
becomes its own reward advanced players
will feel a sense of accomplishment
learning which tactics and attacks work
best against specific classes provided
you can actually tell which class you're
dueling against
the near balanced mix of wide open
spaces and confining passages in all of
lawbreakers maps present a wealth of
combat scenarios that includes turning
the tables on the predator-prey dynamic
or using the environment to gain a
tactical advantage
as with any shooter map time is the only
factor preventing you from committing
every turn shortcut and hiding spot to
memory a common reward for knowing the
layout well is the palpable
gratification of taking a battery or
ball from the center of the map to your
goal in less than 5 seconds in the
overcharged and blitzball modes this map
memory learning curve wouldn't be as
steep if not for all the time you spend
running into locked doors and crossing
invisible boundaries picking awake your
health the maps other shortcoming is the
environmental art style where futuristic
panels displays and corridors can't mask
the arena's uninspired visuals this
richness and functionality and lack of
memorable visuals also applies to
lawbreakers ensemble cast their designs
support the notion that high detail does
not equate to pleasing aesthetics you
only need to look to the class selection
screen to see the fighting game
influence where a large and culturally
diverse group exude personality hungry
for a fight yet despite their array of
outfits and confidence oozing body
language this group largely lacks the
magnetic charisma that inspires loyalty
and discussion of favorite characters in
real life it's a testament to the
combative appeal of lawbreakers that
it's not unusual to engage in brief
isolated duels whether a player's
motivation is to distract an opponent
from the objective or the bloodlust of
notching another kill it's a shame that
there is no deathmatch or team
deathmatch mode to add variety to a
suite of match types centered around
delivering items to goals or dominating
territory
law breakers delivers dopamine hits
beyond the arena through post match
score tallies and letter grading
continuous play also begets higher
player profile levels which yields
lawbreakers cosmetic customization
reward stash crates capitalizing on the
anticipation driven appeal of random
card packs these loot boxes reinforce
lawbreakers replayability given the
unique demands of anti-gravity gameplay
the comprehensive yet concise tutorials
effectively onboard new users which
makes their puzzling omission from the
ps4 version disappointing and the fact
that you're given currency for
participating in the tutorials only
twists the knife to further affirm the
PC version as the preferred platform we
also experience post match glitches that
forced us to relaunch the game from time
to time on ps4 one sign of any
worthwhile team-based shooter is the
level of accessibility where everyone
feels that they can contribute no matter
their play style and law breakers
succeeds in this manner and while the
lack of deathmatch is a lost opportunity
it's sufficient playlists of modes
offers a viable outlet to flaunt your
kill death ratio even if it's at the
expense of team success what counts is
that it's fresh anti-gravity mechanics
transcends its first glance novel appeal
and creates limitless combat situations
that will be new and inviting to many
shooter fans
[Music]
you